i put one in and it falls down and the
volume
goes down to there
this is a syringe with a piston as i
push the piston in here the air will
squirt out the other end
if i put my finger over the end and now
push it up
so it'll start off with 50 oh let's go
up to 30 and see if i can push it that
far yeah i can push it but it gets
harder 25 and the pressure is getting
enormous
and the reason is that the air is made
of little molecules in here which are
bashing away the sides of this and
hitting the piston so if i push it up
they find that this piston there are too
many of them and they're hitting this
piston so much that it's pushing it down
and i have to do work to squeeze this to
get the volume to change so i'd like to
illustrate this using julian to operate
this apparatus because i use these
apparatus and they break down this
apparatus is a scaled up version so you
can see the molecules these molecules
will move around only their steel ball
bearings and they will move up and bash
around as though they are particles in
the air now julian could you turn it on
and we can see how it goes
so now i would like to put in a piston
here is a a polystyrene piston which
more or less fits a thing and will float
down slowly until it covers that now if
you turn it on
gently when it gets down near the bottom
you'll see that it will bash into this
and hold it
and the more energetically julian
puts the energy into this the higher
this piston gets and if he turns it way
up it will move all
the way up
and you can see these particles fasting
into the piston
and as they bash into it it pushes it up
more and more
coming back to my syringe i start off
with the gas particles whizzing around
in here
and as i push this down they hit the top
surface
and bounce off but you can't see them
but that's causing me to have to push
much harder as the volume gets smaller
and smaller there are still the same
number of particles in there but there's
more of them bashing the top surface at
any one time until it gets to the point
where i can't move this any further
because it's too painful on my fingers
so i had to let it go
in the same way oh dear look at that i
mean look i mean it really is painful
we'll turn this on up to full whack and
i'll add these little weights
one at a time and these rates represent
my finger pushing down on the piston so
as i add the first weight and it's got
this volume i put one in and it falls
down and the volume
goes down to there
now i add the second weight here's the
second weight it goes in
and it goes down from there down to
there
now it's put the third one in
and it goes down just a little bit
hardly any change at this stage because
i've already put on two weights third
one's not having much of an effect and
the fourth one it drops down a bit more
thank you julian
each time that i added a little extra
weight you could see the volume decrease
a little bit i put on one it went down a
small amount put on two it went down
even more and as i squash it the volume
changes as i increase the pressure on
the gas by putting more weights on the
piston so the volume decreases